okay let's see who's on the phone today
we've got our first caller from the to10
area code two one zero go right ahead
you can get into your question hello
David
yes yeah this gesture was kind of Tony I
was just asking are you excited for the
World Cup or are you gonna boycott
because things I should know I mean
listen I I hate that the World Cup is in
Russia I hate that the next World Cup is
in Qatar I think it's an absolutely
immoral slave state but I will be
watching every game absolutely no and
not every game but listen Argentina
starts this weekend against Iceland and
I've been following I mean since I was a
little kid I've been following the
Argentinian men's national team so I
will be watching although the schedule
is gonna make it a little tough because
there will be a lot of like 10:00 a.m.
weekday games but I will be watching
yeah and I followed Dave Zirin who says
we can both be activists against the
corruption of a sports institution but
still appreciate the game if that makes
sense yeah well I gotta say I go from
Mexico and every time we go against
Argentina we always get harassed would
by y'all though I don't remember the
last time Argentina played Mexico in the
World Cup I think I think it was in 2008
okay when my favorite diggers made that
battle go but anyways yeah I love the
show later okay thank you so much
appreciate that call and you know Mexico
when Argentina is out Mexico is one of
my favorite World Cup teams yeah and and
i usually go argentina followed by fajr
in Tina's out either Y or cuz they're
kind of like our neighbors down in
Argentina or Mexico fair to say
Argentina will probably make it farther
than those countries right are
supposedly is ranked fourth is what I
heard with something like a four three
or four or now maybe it was like a nine
percent chance of winning it all are we
gonna see the return of your Argentina
Jersey on the show we will indeed we
will indeed yes no doubt about that and
I know that a lot of people will be very
very upset to see me wearing the
Argentina Jersey